body camera footage shows the tense
moments leading up to a deadly shooting
in Texas after a suspect charges police
with a machete in hand Put The Knife
down right now
it happened on January 7th in Fort Worth
Texas investigators say the suspect now
identified as 37 year old Robert
Bradshaw pushed a woman from his vehicle
and later sped up to hit her officials
say the woman was severely injured in
the crash after the hit and run Bradshaw
went to his mother's house and he's
going crazy
and I'm just really scared I think I
think he needs some mental evaluation
both Bradshaw's mother and sister call
9-1-1 saying they are concerned for
their safety do you know if he has any
weapons
I guess you're not but I'm not sure
body camera video shows two officers
arrive at the home to find Bradshaw
standing in the doorway with a large
machete style knife officers then
repeatedly tell Bradshaw to drop the
knife
can we come in
here
hey Put The Knife down here
when Bradshaw refuses to drop the weapon
officers get ready to use a Taser on him
at that same moment Bradshaw rushes them
with the weapon in hand that's when both
officers fire Put The Knife down right
now no get your taser get your taser
Bradshaw died as a result of his
injuries in a video statement Fort Worth
Police say both officers were in quote
fear for their life at the time of the
shooting it's now in the preliminary
stages of an investigation once
completed the results will be turned
over to the Tarrant County District
Attorney's Office reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie